I want to pull up this tweet here
because this is a really good point
former VP of global comms Brandon Borman
asks can we truthfully claim that this
is part of the policy and this goes to
show that when they censor the hunter
Biden laptop internally they knew they
had fabricated a reason for censoring
politically damaging information on the
Democrats and this is him saying can we
can we truthfully claim that's part of
the policy like the Hacked materials
thing when this story dropped and they
said you can't publish hacked things
everyone went you just made that up
there's at the same time as they're
saying you can't do that there were
other hacked materials that were going
around disparaging people like Trump
what about the the the taxes and stuff
like that right files that get leaked
they never cared about now all of a
sudden they made up a fake policy to
enforce it's not just that we can see
Democrats were well connected and they
were Banning people we can see in
internally they were struggling with
some kind of way to publicly justify
overt political bias to benefit
Democrats and look at look how brilliant
it was again I want to give them credit
look how brilliant it was that even when
they knew they screwed up and obviously
she just pointed out they knew they
screwed up they still didn't pull back
they didn't pull back because they knew
they only had the last of the election
the right would never do something like
this the writers spent the last week and
a half tripping all over themselves to
denounce this and condemn that and I I
absolutely condemned this oh my goodness
don't associate me with that they don't
think in those terms they're thinking
hey let's just batten down the hatches
for three weeks who cares if we're a
bunch of dirty Liars let's win an
election we'll hash it out at the end it
is the one of the best quotes I've heard
I can't remember who said it Republicans
care more about the opinion of the New
York Times than the opinion of their
constituents 100 yes if people if people
really understood how these people how
the Republican Party talks about their
base behind their back they'd probably
vote Democrat that's how that is that's
how bad it is they have such disrespect
for their base they they spit in their
face all the time over and over and over
and over and over again I can't stand it
it's totally defuncture party it's
garbage but but Maga party changed it a
bit the the Maga candidates who came in
are are different from the established
Republicans but the established
Republicans still have control of the
whole thing yeah like Trump did come in
and take control in a certain respect
but you can see how 2016 to 2018 no you
know Paul Ryan like the Republicans had
everything and got nothing done
Republicans side with Democrats on the
Russia gate nonsense and then you you
get into uh the next phase and then you
end up with Republicans outright just
going and joining Democrats neocon
Republicans forming political action
committees saying we're just going after
Trump and then as soon as Trump is out
they say well you know it's the it's
trumpism it's it's trumpism so they were
they were never honest oh were you gonna
say yes I'm sorry in 15 15 Republicans
voted with Democrats on a gun control
Bill nobody can name free nobody no one
can name for me one time 15 Democrats
crossed over and voted with the GOP on a
Republican bill nobody can name that
this is a really good example that
Michael Mouse brought up on the show a
while ago he said something to the
effect of Republicans compromise every
time on gun control Democrats like when
have you seen a republican campaign on
we're going to repeal the NFA we're
going to repeal gun control it's always
say nothing and then say well we'll
we'll give a little bit to the Democrats
on gun control so that's that's the gag
it's Republicans Or democrats go on the
speed limit of course gun control is
such a manipulated phrase because in
order you have to learn how to control a
gun gun control is like your hand
manipulation of the weapon and for them
to say that like banning guns is a form
of control is like it's just a
disgusting it's you know they control
the language too especially when they
control social media so we got to start
changing these things it's not gun
control it's disarming lawful citizens
in order to make them future victims how
do we summarize that and make that into
a short phrase so it's catchy but but
again again language is key and a lot of
the times the Republicans are just a
part of the uni party yeah they're a
part of a system that serves a special
corporate class and whether it's you
know multinational corporations whether
it's big Banks there's a lot of other
influential people that are a lot more
powerful than politicians that are truly
pulling the strings here and Republicans
and Democrats I don't care at the end of
the day they serve not you not the
people they serve someone else beyond
the you know people with the government
I live in Texas Big Oil state right
everyone knows Texas Big Oil say not
only Red State but a big oil state in my
red state of Texas and I live in a blood
red part of a blood red state of Texas
every single two every two years when
they're running for house you can watch
Republican congressmen in safe seats in
safe seats run commercials talking about
reduced carbon we can reduce carbon or
we can reduce the second you've told
everybody the second you've given the
ground that carbon is poisoned you've
already lost to the climate change
Nutters and this these are people who
could safely say I love carbon I want
more carbon build coal plants build
everything and said well we can reduce
carbon guys we got another tweet that
just came in from Matt taibi and
pertaining to the Hacked materials
policy he says the problem with the
Hacked materials ruling several sources
said was that this normally required an
official law enforcement finding of a
hack but such a finding never appears
throughout what one executive describes
as a whirlwind 24-hour company-wide mess
Let Me simplify this for you guys they
said okay we can justify suppressing
this really really bad news about the
political party we like under our hacked
policy a hacked materials policy and
they said but it wasn't hacked it was
found it was found uh what do we do all
hands on deck I guess we're going to
just lie about it they could they could
they they could not justify their own
policy which everyone knew was BS
they like they they made up a rule to
suppress this that couldn't they
couldn't even satisfy it their fake rule
could not even be satisfied so they just
did it anyway yeah there probably was
other Communications that we still don't
know about between vinjaya and the
Department of Homeland Security and
probably the Federal Bureau of
Investigations if you remember a couple
months ago Mark Zuckerberg came out on
the Joe Rogan uh podcast and said
specifically you know the FBI came to us
they said that there was hacked
information and then we should be
careful of this and this led us to of
course stop the hunter Biden a laptop
story from being shared so this was not
just Twitter doing this this was
Facebook this was Instagram this was
Google this was YouTube all the big Tech
social media companies made the same
decision at the same time so is this
Olive in Jaya no there's probably
another secret kind of backdoor
Communications between a lot of these
heads that really do call the shots at a
lot of these networks and of course the
government saying you better do this or
else now they probably signed a lot of
non-disclosures there's probably a lot
of secret Communications I think this
this is only just scratching the surface
of what we're finding out here and I
think it gets a lot more Sinister a lot
more deeper when you see this story not
just censored by Twitter but censored by
everybody at the same time coincidence I
don't believe so I don't believe in
coincidences coincidences are just uh
secrets that the government is hiding
from uh everything we're learning within
the last few days we'll remember too
that the Facebook thing a lot of people
actually don't realize this they
remember the Mark Zuckerberg thing and
they remember him talking to Joe Rogan
and saying the FBI came to us what many
people do not understand is the time
frame of that the FBI did not go to
Facebook and tell them to censor the
hunter Biden's story after the hunter
Biden story was published the FBI
because they were tapping Rudy
giuliani's phones and everything else
because they were spying on him they
preempted the publication of the story
and went to Facebook before the hunter
Biden story was published and told them
it's coming it's Russian information
what I want to make sure you censor it
that is so much more frightening than
anything thing else that's going on to
understand that the Checker currently
operates within the borders of the
United States of America and people
don't realize it they don't have any
idea exactly how frightening things are
happening at the doj and FBI that's Way
Beyond Twitter that is scary stuff was
that is that confirmed that they they
went before the Story released correct
you talked to Miranda Devine great great
columnist at the New York Post she's uh
super sharp she'll explain the whole
thing for you the whole time frame they
went to the Facebook before the story
they spied stole the information then
preempted the story
this is this is another important this
is another important aspect here because
they said it was Russian disinformation
they knew it wasn't because they
interviewed Tony bobolinski that
confirmed the story they knew the laptop
was real they knew everything inside of
that laptop was legitimate they had the
evidence they had everything in front of
them and then they decided at the FBI
well this is this is going to hurt Biden
let's just turn this into Russian this
information let's go around tell
everyone that this is it preemptively
which is even more Sinister than you
know venjaya just saying I don't like
this bye and people need to when you
look at history you look at the monsters
of History those have certainly been
coming up a lot recently you know the
various monstrous dictators of history
from Mao to Stalin to Hitler and all
these people they're all coming up what
people do realize that Mao and Stalin
and Hitler after they took power didn't
actually kill anyone right their State
Police did yeah if you have the building
of a state police that's loyal to only
one party within the borders of the
United States of America whether people
realize it or not there's nothing else
that comes close to the danger of that
if the Federal Bureau of the
investigation is now fully the
enforcement arm of the democratic party
that that that trumps inflation that
trumps the border that trumps taxes
there's nothing else that matters unless
that is stopped that will end the United
States of America it will they have the
power to destroy anybody already and
that's only getting worse did you see
the Chinese bussing people like grabbing
citizens and taking them put them on
buses like there's no one to protect
them we you can't invade I mean you
cannot I don't think ethically we could
not invade to stop it it just caused
more hell so we sit and watch as they
bust their citizens off to concentration
camps well why would we invade when our
government's on the same side as China
our government already came out recently
and said no no what Elon Musk is doing
at Twitter man we're keeping an eye on
that oh apple is actually actively
helping the Chinese Communist Party
crush the Freedom Fighters oh well
that's a private company not our big
deal our government works with China
we're they're not they're not unopened
yeah I mean there's a reason Klaus
Schwab said that China is a role model
for many countries moving forward for
the new world as as he described it and
and again what's happening in China is
what's going to be happening here if we
keep on this trajectory of allowing
Federal authorities to abuse their power
to hurt people because of their
political expression and to suppress
larger ideas of discontent and debate
we're seeing an intervention in our
society that is destroying any kind of
legitimate pushback against an
illegitimate Authority that is abusing
their power and it's extremely dangerous
if we keep on this road we got the final
wrap up from Matt's Ivy he says it's
been a whirlwind 96 hours for me too
there is much more to come including
answers to questions about issues like
Shadow Banning boosting follower counts
the fate of various individual accounts
and more these issues are not limited to
the political right good night everyone
thanks to all those who picked up the
phone in the last few days good work
Matt
and that's fantastic he's been he's been
doing a good job for a long time Elon
too nice work man yeah yeah absolutely
that's that's gutsy to buy a company and
then put that out there he didn't have
to do that
I I get why Vijaya got it was crying
every single time more information comes
out she never thought somebody could
muster up 44 billion dollars to buy the
company she thought she was invincible
and now her private Communications are
being exposed to show the malfeasance I
wonder if she thought that she'd get
thrown in prison if she said no and just
went printed it anyway I don't think
that woman needed any convincing to
crush her enemies on the right I think
she would licking her chops the second
she got the opportunity to who's gonna
throw her in prison the FBI she'll
probably be their director next year
that's right yeah she'll be the chief
legal trust and safety team if she
wasn't working for them the whole time
already yeah right I mean that's a fair
speculation to make here what if she was
just working for the feds the whole time
that's possible but I mean the
difference between an informant and an
employee is like nil in this environment
they just PayPal you 700 000 bit or
seven dollars in Bitcoin into some
wallet and then you're not you don't
have to work for them to be you know
working for them yeah the FBI just got
done plotting the assassination and
kidnapping of the governor of Michigan
which we now know because of that trial
where they found two boobs who were
living in the basement of some vacuum
cleaner place and a bunch of feds came
in and bribed these guys to come that
they paid for and organized every bit of
the the plot and then they gave the guy
the explosives and then busted him with
the explosives they gave that guy and
then charged it with them and they had
more feds than they actually had
legitimate people that were stupid
enough to hang around the feds that's
true this is the Gretchen Whitmer case
yes yeah yeah that's real Insanity it's
what the FBI does it creates villains so
that there's a reason for the FBI to
exist correct I mean there is real Mafia
on Earth that we could be focusing
there's a quick meme that I just posted
really quickly of the FBI being really
happy and giddy looking at someone uh
there's that black guy in the yellow
suit kind of uh grasping his hands and
over there is just someone who's alone
he doesn't have any friends that is
mentally ill and it's the FBI looking
over at that individual I'll tell you
what I think the FBI is going after the
political opponents of the current
Administration pro-life activists are
getting raided people who are
incorrectly associated with January 16
had their homes rated and then the
protesters that are Marching In Front of
the justices homes illegally are well
they're fine right and so what happens
is that's what the FBI is doing they're
weaponized not every single FBI agent
they're they're you know I've I've had
dealing with law enforcement based on
the stuff we've gone through and so I I
think it's a it's a corrupt element with
very much high power in the DC but what
happens is every so often they need to
justify their budget so they have
specific teams it's like okay you know
we're gonna go before Congress we need
more money you guys go stage a fake
Terror threat so that we can parade in
front of the press and then we can get
our budgets pumped up and I'm sure it's
just an accident that fake rich and
Whitmer plot it got publicized October
right before the election right when
they're trying to build a narrative of
the vine the right Wingers miraculously
all the arrests were made and an October
surprise I'm sure that's just a total
coincidence and speaking of January 6th
and people unfairly associated with it
what about the people who actually are
associated with it and they're still not
being treated fairly we talk about China
and their human rights abuses all the
time and rightfully so because China is
a piece of trash country well their
government's piece of trash but in the
United States of America as we speak we
have United States citizens who have
been held without trial now for two
years if you watch Vladimir Putin do
that you'd hear every single Tom Dick
and Harry in this country talk about how
he's a dictator and that's horrible and
I'm just glad I live in the west that's
happening right now in the United States
of America I don't care what you did too
I don't care if you murdered somebody
two years without trial you're being
unfairly treated by the justice system
let alone sauntering into the capital
and snapping a selfie in front of Nancy
Pelosi's desk and you're holding these
guys in terrible conditions for two
years that's not some distant dystopian
future that's right now the country you
live in you know or uh we're frogs in a
pot if the water starts boiling because
I say it often but if you were to
describe the events of this year last
year the year before to someone six
seven years ago they would tell you you
were lying 100 like imagine going to
someone in 2015 being like what's 2020
after the pandemic and Donald Trump's
presidency there was a risk of War
because China they had concentration
camps what are you talking about well
Elon Musk he bought Twitter right what
yeah you know man when they were signing
the uh National Defense authorization
act or or the Patriot Act if they were
like oh and by the way before we sign
this we just want to let you know in 20
years we're going to arrest 200 people
that when there's a ride at the Capitol
I'd be like uh wait and then well how
many people did they kill they didn't
kill anybody
but we're gonna throw them in prison for
two years it's funny you brought up the
Patriot Act Ian because man I've been
wrong about a lot I've screwed up a lot
of things in my life but when the
Patriot Act when all that stuff was
going down I was a young hothead I that
was a marine at the time and I was like
yeah screw those terrorists oh quit
being paranoid and they're not going to
use it on us let's go kill all the
terrorists tap all their phones and all
the Ron Paul people were all super loud
about it no they're going to use it on
citizens and I remember I remember oh
you guys are idiots stop being paranoid
if you didn't do anything wrong you
don't have to worry about it man did
they get that one right or not I was
screaming like don't you guys read
history yeah do you understand what
happened
the the gun or the knife that you make
is going to be pointed back at you
eventually and that's that's the problem
with government too many people believe
government's going to be their solution
and they keep empowering it by giving it
more legitimacy and I think truly uh the
best way to do this to push away is to
be personally responsible and not need
government and not to call for more
government so this is why I've been
standing strong in my views for for such
long about this one particular aspect
which I think is important but thank you
for you know you know admitting it uh
and and talking about it because a lot
of other people were like you know
either one ignore it don't want to think
about it or two or doubling down and
like yeah we need more National Security
and I'm like do you see what they're
doing yeah no we need to eliminate
virtually every Federal agency and
anything short of that's going to result
in the end of the country that's what we
need yeah
absolutely
uh yeah God welcome to the modern
dystopian my friends yeah it's it's it
gets Crazier by the minute and there are
a lot of people I see on Twitter where
they're like ah you know not necessarily
on Twitter but I hear people saying like
something I've heard consistently is
that it's not that crazy things are not
getting crazier it's just people are
grifting or whatever or they're trying
to get views or clicks and I'm just like
Elon Musk bought Twitter like a
billionaire mustered up 44 billion
dollars bought one of the big three
social networks and now he's leaking
internal Communications proving
malfeasance like it is getting crazier
things are escalating now this is good
news though I think I think we've had a
tremendously good uh past couple of
weeks especially with what Elon is doing
and so you know I'm not saying it's it's
like
it is getting bad in a lot of ways but
the night is always darkest for the dawn
these are these are the things that need
to happen before we can start fixing
them we got to see the we got to see the
the malfeasance exposed agreed oh well
we're going to have we're gonna have I I
call our corrupt I call it the system
you know the government coordinating
with the media coordinating with the
pharmaceutical companies coordinating
with education the administrative state
they're all they all believe the same
thing now all of our cultural
institutions have been taken over and I
call it the system and there are going
to be system disruptors that arise I
would argue Donald Trump was the first
of those so here's to very much to his
credit he was the first of those Elon
Musk is very clearly a system disrupter
as well now bad news for Donald Trump
and bad news for Elon Musk the system's
very powerful and has a way of Smashing
those disruptors I actually I'm one of
the ones who's very pessimistic about
Elon Musk I say he's either going to
bend the knee or he's going to wish he
had at the end but then another one will
rise and another one will rise because
we're not a minority the people who are
watching us right now and nodding their
heads and agreeing they feel alone
they're tens of millions of us so
there'll be more system disruptors who
rise I think Elon made a bet
he's on Twitter he sees what gets
engagement and what doesn't and what
gets engagement tends to be
Centrist to write populist you know
content he likes it it speaks to him he
considers himself a Centrist he puts up
a poll should we have a peace deal to
stop the war with Ukraine Russia and at
first it was like yes peace but then all
of a sudden it started shifting to no
war and he says that these are Bots all
these people start making fun of him oh
you didn't go your way sir blame and
bought so he says okay let's find out he
buys the company
he then does the Trump poll 52 to 48
reinstate Trump he then publicly says it
was interesting to see the Bots attack
he then does another poll should we
Grant General amnesty now it's 72
percent support we mentioned this the
other day how do you go from 52 saying
yes to unbanning Trump
to 72 saying unban everyone he purged
the Bots The Narrative was constructed
it was fake and he knows he has popular
support oh he does that well that's
that's what happens with the like like a
Julius Caesar type I mean everyone knows
who Julius Caesar is when he was rising
up and fighting against the corrupt
system whatever you think of him that's
what he was doing he got he got he was
able to do that though because he had
the support of so many people that in
the fact he was a better General than
anyone else who lived including Pompey
Magnus at the time but when you have
this many people even if there was no
Trump no Elon there would still be
another who would pop up and when they
get done destroying Trump and done
destroying Elon the next one who pops up
there will be another one who pops up
because when you have tens of millions
of people who don't want to live in a
Despicable late stage Republic like we
have now they will eventually choose for
themselves someone to rise thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time